- [Kim] Hi, this is Kim from Kahn Academy
and today we're learning more
about McDonald versus Chicago,
a 2010 Supreme Court case
challenging a handgun ban
in the city of Chicago.
The question at issue was whether
the 14th Amendment's due
process or privileges
or immunities clause means
that the 2nd Amendment right
to keep and bear arms for
the purposes of self defense
is applicable to the states
or, put more plainly,
the 2nd Amendment says
the federal government
can't infringe on citizens'
rights to keep and bear arms,
but can state governments?
To learn more about
McDonald versus Chicago,
I talked to two experts.
Alan Gura is a lawyer who
argued McDonald versus Chicago
before the Supreme Court.
Elizabeth Wydra is a
Supreme Court litigator and
the president of the Constitutional
Accountability Center.
So, Miss Wydra, could
you set the stage for us?
Who were the challengers
in this case and why
did they decide to sue?
- [Elizabeth] The lead plaintiff
is or was Otis McDonald,
then 76 year old African American retired
maintenance engineer who
lived in a part of Chicago
and wanted to have a gun
for self defense, a handgun,
to protect himself and
his family in his home.
He lived in a neighborhood that had grown
increasingly troubled with
gang and drug related violence
and he felt that he
wanted to have a handgun
to protect his wife and
his family after his home
had been broken into several times.
But because the city of
Chicago had strict rules
barring handguns, he and
three other Chicago residents
brought their case into
court asking the court
to find that the individual
right to keep and bear arms,
including a handgun for
self defense in the home
that had been recognized
just a few years earlier
by the Supreme Court with respect
to the federal government,
also applies to the states
and cities like Chicago.
- [Alan] In 2008, the
Supreme Court had held
that the 2nd Amendment to the Constitution
guarantees Americans
the right to have guns
for the purpose of self
defense, but that case
took place in Washington
D.C., and Washington D.C.
is sort of a unique creature in our law.
It's a federal city, it's not located
in any particular state, and so everything
that the city of Washington
does is essentially
done by the federal government or a unit
of the federal government
to which the Bill of Rights
applies directly, but
historically, the Bill of Rights
was never thought to
apply directly to limit
what cities and states could do.
- [Kim] So what were some
of competing interpretations
that were at issue in this case?
- [Alan] Well, there were
a number of interpretations
that were at issue.
The 14th Amendment has
several parts to it.
In the first section
of the 14th Amendment,
it states that, "no state
shall make or enforce
"any law which shall
abridge the privileges
"or immunities of citizens
of the United States."
And then it also says, among other things,
that "states can't deprive
people of due process
"when it comes time to
regulating their life, liberty,
"or property."
States may not deprive anyone
of life, liberty, or property
without due process of law.
When it comes to your basic civil rights,
the question had always
been whether or not
the states are bound not to
violate your civil rights
because they are told not
to abridge the privileges
or immunities of American
citizens or are your rights
not to be violated because
the states can't deprive you
of due process of law.
- [Elizabeth] So when the
drafters of the 14th Amendment
were coming together to
think about what rights
would be protected in the 14th Amendment,
they looked at a lot of the
abuses by state governments
of key rights that had
been previously protected
against federal government
action in the Bill of Rights.
And when they were debating
what rights would be included
in these protections against state action,
they talked repeatedly
about the importance
of the right to keep and bear arms.
But the way they talked
about it was very different
from the way that we think
about the 18th century
revolutionary founders talking
about the right to keep and bear arms.
In that case, it was very
much about the militia
and preventing the tyranny
of government action.
In the 14th Amendment
context, the right to keep
and bear arms was very
much an individual right.
They were concerned about
freed persons being subject
to white militia violence and being able
to protect themselves
with a gun in their house,
and so that was really
one of the ways in which
they wanted to protect the
individual right to keep
and bear arms, different
from the way that I think
the founders thought about
it when they were drafting
the 2nd Amendment.
- [Kim] Yeah, this is a
really interesting point
because you can kind of
see how these things evolve
over time and particularly in the 1860s
after the Civil War, there are
many local or state statutes
known as the Black Codes
that specifically prevented
newly free African Americans
from owning firearms
or any kind of weapon.
- [Elizabeth] Exactly,
and that was a concern
because, one, it was a
right that they considered
to be a right of citizenship,
but two, and more practically
and more immediately of
concern for the people
who were being targeted
by this racial violence,
it was something that was a question
of life or death for them,
and the debates on this
by the drafters of the 14th
Amendment were very clear
and very colorful.
Senator Samuel Pomeroy
described how indispensable
the right to keep and bear arms was
and how important it was
that the 14th Amendment
protect that right.
He said during the debates,
"every man should have
"the right to bear arms
for the defense of himself,
"and family, and his homestead.
"And if the cabin door of
the freedman is broken open,
"and the intruder enters
for purposes as vile
"as were known to slavery, then
should a well-loaded musket
"be in the hand of the occupant,
to send the polluted wretch
"to another world, where his wretchedness
"will forever remain complete."
- [Kim] So going back
to the McDonald case,
how did the court rule in this case?
- [Alan] In McDonald,
we made two arguments
for why we should win.
The first argument we
made was the historically
more obvious one, although
it's one that the courts
had not often entertained,
and that's the argument
that says that when the
14th Amendment provided
that the people cannot be
deprived of the privileges
or immunities of American citizenship.
That means they couldn't be deprived
of their basic fundamental rights.
Right there in the text
of the 14th Amendment
it tells you that you can't
be deprived of the rights
of American citizenship.
Secondly, we made the
argument that, and this is
the argument that the courts
have been more open to
over the years, we made the
argument that where the state
is prohibited from depriving Otis McDonald
and other Chicago residents
of due process of law,
and you can't deprive
someone of due process.
That means not just that the state
can do things arbitrarily,
not just that Otis McDonald
is entitled to some procedural protections
in the way that he's regulated,
but also that there's
some results, some things
that simply cannot be
done, and taking away
someone's firearms in violation
of the 2nd Amendment rights
is not something that the state can do.
There's no procedure that
the state could create
to achieve that.
They would still be considered to be
giving somebody due process of law.
- [Elizabeth] So the court
said what we have done
when we've looked at individual rights
under the 14th Amendment,
and whether or not
original Bill of Rights
rights that were initially
understood to limit the federal government
applied to the states,
is look at whether or not
they are part of what
we generally talk about
as fundamental to our
scheme of ordered liberty,
or stated another way, the
question is whether the right
is firmly rooted in this
nation's history and tradition,
and when they looked at
that question with respect
to the right to keep and
bear arms, they looked at
a lot of the Reconstruction
history and said
this was clearly something
that the drafters
of the 14th Amendment considered
to be very fundamental
to ordered liberty and
thought that, indeed,
the freedmen, the African
American people of the South
who had been subject to the slave power
and people across the
country who'd been subject
to discrimination from
the states should be able
to look to the Constitution
to protect the right
to keep and bear arms as
their individual right,
just as the court had
held in the Heller case,
they could be able to
look to the Constitution
for protection of that right
against the federal government.
- [Kim] So in the McDonald
case, how did the majority
of the court rule?
- [Alan] The justices broke
down in multiple different ways.
There were four justices,
led by Justice Alito,
who refused to look any
further at the privileges
or immunities clause.
They thought it was old, it
was water under the bridge.
They were not interested in looking to see
whether or not the courts
erasing of that provision
was legitimate, even it's widely agreed
to be illegitimate today, but the court
didn't wanna go there, and
instead those four justices,
led by Justice Alito, held
that the due process clause
incorporates the 2nd Amendment
right to keep and bear arms
as against the states because
it is a fundamental right.
It's deeply rooted in our
nation's history and traditions.
It's something that's very
basic to our understanding
of our civil and political institutions.
The four justices thought the
right to keep and bear arms
is fundamental.
- [Elizabeth] There was actually
a debate among the members
of the majority who all
believe that there was a right
to have a handgun in the
house for self defense
that was protected against state
and local government
regulations, but Justice Thomas
would have found that right
through another means.
He would have looked at the
privileges or immunities clause
of the 14th Amendment, instead
of the now accepted method
of looking at due process liberty clause
of the 14th Amendment, which
is how these other provisions
of the Bill of Rights
have been incorporated
against the states.
There were many arguments,
including, I should say,
a brief that I filed on behalf of scholars
from across the ideological spectrum
who said that, in fact, the
privileges or immunities clause
of the 14th Amendment is the part
of that constitutional
amendment that was intended
to protect this particular
substantive right
as well as the other substantive rights
of the Bill of Rights
against state infringement,
just as Thomas'
concurrence did not get any
of the other votes,
whether from the people
who were against the right
to keep and bear arms
or those who didn't, but it
is an important contribution
to thinking about how we understand rights
and where they are protected
in the Constitution.
- [Alan] Justice Thomas'
opinion in McDonald
is groundbreaking.
It represents the first time since 1868
that the original meaning
of the 14th Amendment's
privileges or immunities
clause, the basic protection
that we have for civil
rights in this country
against state and local
governments was decisive
in a case at the Supreme Court.
It's been that long since a
true original understanding
of the 14th Amendment's
language has finally proven
to be decisive.
- [Elizabeth] There
were, of course, justices
who thought that there is
not an individual right
to have a handgun in the
home for self defense.
These were the same
justices, not surprisingly,
who thought there wasn't
a 2nd Amendment right
to be protected against
federal government action
to keep a handgun in the
home for self defense.
They would've thought that
this was much more a right
in the 2nd Amendment
context that had to do
with militia service, military service,
and therefore did not extend
to an individual right
to have a gun in the
home for self defense.
- [Alan] McDonald's really
a 14th Amendment case.
I mean, guns happen to be
the thing that was in it,
but I'd always seen as primarily
is a 14th Amendment case.
It's not really a case
that tells you anything
about the scope of the 2nd Amendment.
In fact, it doesn't say
anything about the scope
of the 2nd Amendment, very little.
- [Elizabeth] There are many
issues left to be resolved
in the 2nd Amendment context.
The Heller case itself,
which first articulated
that there was a right for
individuals to keep and bear arms
in their homes for self defense made clear
that it wasn't saying that there
could be no gun regulation.
That case, even though it was
written by Justice Scolia,
and certainly in the McDonald case,
Justice Alito's majority
opinion reiterated this,
said that while there were certain laws
that would be struck
down as unconstitutional
because they prohibited
the possession of handguns
in the home, they
recognized at the same time
that the right to keep and
bear arms is not a right
to keep and carry any weapon whatsoever
in any manner whatsoever,
and for whatever purpose,
so given that the court itself,
and even very conservative
justices recognize
that there could be and perhaps should be
common sense limitations
on both the types of guns
that are allowed, the manner
in which they are allowed,
and where they can be
taken and in what manner,
then a lot of the gun
regulations that are being passed
are still very much a part
of the constitutional debate.
We've seen, frankly, most
of the laws, thus far,
be upheld as constitutional
laws, that, for example,
target assault weapons,
high capacity magazines,
and certain licensing and
registration requirements.
So I think we will see more
cases to define the contours
of the individual right
to keep and bear arms
as these gun regulations get passed
and as the courts get to pass
upon their constitutionality.
- [Kim] So we've learned
that the Supreme Court ruled
that the 14th Amendment's
due process clause
that no state can deprive
a citizen of life,
liberty, or property
without due process of law,
did incorporate the 2nd
Amendment into the states
under the reasoning that the
right to keep and bear arms
for self defense is fundamental
to the nation's scheme
of ordered liberty.
According to Alan Gura,
even though this case
was about guns, it was
really a 14th Amendment case
concerning whether states can
restrict citizens' liberty.
Elizabeth Wydra, however,
cautions that the decision
in McDonald didn't preclude any
restriction on gun ownership
and she suspects that
new cases will continue
to define the individual
right to keep and bear arms.
To learn more about this case,
visit the National Constitution Center's
interactive Constitution,
and Kahn Academy's resources
on US Government and Politics.